cette étude sur des quartiers
prioritaires de la ville a permis de
disposer enfin d'informations assez
précises au niveau des quartiers sur le
taux de pauvreté sur le taux de chômage
des habitants et sur les différences
qu'il ya entre les quartiers prêts dits
prioritaires de la ville et le reste des
communes
qu'est-ce qu'il en ressorte contient un
certain nombre d'éléments qui ont un
sens auquel on ne s'attendait pas
forcément notamment sur la proposition
de ces quartiers ne sont pas tous
composés de la même population tout à
fait alors il ya des quartiers il ya
deux types de quartier les quartiers qui
sont à forte composante de hlm donc où
la population relativement homogène
relativement jeunes avec des enfants des
bouteilles de ménage assez importante et
une homogénéité de la population en
termes de ressources et de revenus à
côté on a des quartiers qui sont plus
particulier je prends l'exemple de voler
la plage où là on a beaucoup d'habitats
individuels avec des personnes seules et
les personnes souvent âgées
les applications de cette avancée
environ 7 à quoi va servir cette
cartographie dans cette cartographie va
permettre aux pouvoirs publics et aux
décideurs à l'économie locaux de pouvoir
évaluer si le périmètre actuel des
quartiers prioritaires de la ville
correspond bien aux besoins
donc est ce qu'il ne faudrait pas soit
les tendres soit le réduit où trouver
d'autres quartiers ailleurs qui seraient
susceptibles de bénéficier de la
politique de la ville